right on time
we are live right on time we are live we
are right right on time right on time I
need to get better at my time management
skills alright this is not okay eight
minutes late that's a new record for me
I'll take it damn I'm the real I I hate
to let you guys down the reason I think
I'm so optimistic about time is that I
want to have more time to stream and I
know oh okay I'll get all my stuff done
and then then we can get going
but then that's just not the reality a
lot of the case I have a lot of [ __ ] to
do so here we are we're live thank you
for waiting for the final conclusion
I'll go to the peepee wall of shame if
that's what it takes if that's what it
takes
hey privilege of being a man don't have
to worry about looking like [ __ ] this is
great the [ __ ] is his hair damn it
where's the gameplay BuChE BuChE the
frame looks good and look I look this
way
awful [ __ ] sake nevermind god [ __ ]
damn it I thought I fixed it why you
doing this to me
alright what does this work [ __ ] BAM
look I looked this way now it's like I'm
looking at the gameplay gamers
changing the game have a go
I did a test before I went live just to
make sure I won't have to deal with this
while being live like all the other
[ __ ] things pop out chant so I can
read you guys [ __ ] oh yeah I have the
headset now [ __ ] I forgot never mind not
important not important God of big
donations are they aware to go where are
you mr. biggie
there was someone saying they waited a
long time I'm sorry yeah
turn up mic even more even more I can
speak louder how about have you ever
thought that you maybe you guys are too
loud so apparently I can plug in
headphones in my controller does that
work there was a headphone jack I didn't
know hold up hold that I didn't know
Dave Goodis I
all right let's try this works if it
doesn't I'm not gonna spend a minute
plugging in BAM had no idea you can do
that we're living in the future guys how
long is this console been out can I hear
no I [ __ ] can't I think I actually
have to go into the cell but then he
might not output then he might not I'm
put for you guys I said I wouldn't spend
a minute but now my brain can't handle a
primary output take it all no [ __ ] it I
can still hear the game don't you don't
[ __ ] matter you don't [ __ ] matter
hey don't matter cuz why because we had
bricks that wasn't a brick but I wish it
was a B gameplay has been kind of cool I
was thinking about the game yesterday
couldn't if they started off with a B
instead it could have been so much
better I wouldn't hate her immediately
what if the game just started with I
have his whole journey that way you come
in with it with a more of an open mind
instead it's like you love a B now hey
guess what abby's your favorite
character stability now or need I don't
suck then then I'm willing to forgive a
lot of the creamy [ __ ] in the game I
really am but it's just too much man
it's too much
alright faster reload nice sweet shout a
hold P is button to go sound devices
[ __ ]
speaker for controller it's on it didn't
it didn't give me any audio and I can't
give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] I don't
care I just want to play the game I miss
the man in the game I'm not gonna lie
okay so we're here now
yeah all right there were over the fence
or anything yeah I selected my own
little cozy cabin let's say hi oh oh
they're dead they're dead you still
there they're dead
how did Abby not okay they shoot arrows
that's why I didn't hear it's me
thisis game could have ended there we
were close sorry
how's she doing
remember if you die in a flashback your
day in real life
I almost got a hurt bra
Thank You Alvin likewise whatever that
means
lean into me where are you taking her
come on this is how I feel playing this
banjo I'm giving her a chance
[Music]
a flashback I'm in flashback I love it
oh and getting what's that messages my
back in hey go and wake up up here those
scars I need whatever medical supplies
you have no she live Lord the bow it's
okay Abby who are these kids
they saved my life can you take a look
at her good dog this is your ax
what did this hammer it wasn't [ __ ]
hammer castle hammers Slayer die can you
feel this
Yara no I was gonna clean it and try
this bone shattered oh it needs to be
amputation compartment syndrome what
does that mean it means it has to come
off you can't take our arm
leave it it'll turned gangrenous oh just
stop hurting please give this woman some
whiskey God Damon
ideally I saw sutures clamps antibiotics
I we're far from ideal right now we have
knives fire cut cauterize it she would
die from infection make me a list I'll
go to the hospital again what do think
he want a to get there I don't mind it's
not about you Abby she doesn't have a
couple of days but if I can get you
there in two hours
the wolf Hospital right on the west side
how is this gonna be gory we built
bridges high up it's how we get around
the flooding and you people
can she handle two hours probably yeah
so make a list wait are you serious
these bridges are used by scars they
only somehow feel like this time you
heard that small groups this isn't a
joke
all right we have a shopping list let's
go
do I look pregnant right now Abby
good morning gamers here we go four more
hours of Abby let's go
let's finish days what'd you steal my
keys sorry can I talk to you talk why
are you doing this because Abby really
cares about the people she knows who
saves her life my camera stopped working
with the book well I do why
[Music]
well you got a cat that's pretty cool
hola hope you know what you're doing
my overheated to be honest because
it's so got it I swear it's like 29
degrees in here
okay I might just play it without for 30
minutes to let it cool down sorry about
that
FS in the chat your friends are wolves -
yeah
we were lucky Mills there she's one of
the best surgeons in Seattle
what's his name the man Oh
how do we get to the really tall
buildings the bridges there no really
tall buildings you're gonna be able to
get us the rest of the way starts yeah
we ran here in the dark that's kind of
cool get us they're seeing it now that
is bright just pour some water on the
bridges are really gonna get us over the
rapids yeah yes in just a couple hours
I'm not lying
okay the movie green filter really works
in this usually it's kind of annoying
I'm just reloading my camera guys
reloading my brake there it is
Thank You Nick Roth our legend that's
the building we need to get to okay I
see it I can't [ __ ] see it it's all
foggy
what happens
she'll have to try to do the surgery
with what growing husband
keep out of the water these Rapids will
rip you away
oh well you can just jump in you know
how do we do a gamer right
that was working okay yeah just stay put
you know when you're jumping sometimes a
running start
I know how to jump water spud something
doesn't look like we can go
Wolffe you want to help me out here
I don't think this is it I saw another
pass over here
yeah found it
problems guys worries
highly Withers god damn yes and generous
today thank you
they didn't even have to balance let me
guess locked
[ __ ] sink
got some nice chairs 10 out of 10
gameplay that's some nice [ __ ] chair
ever just stop and look at chairs oh yes
sorry my friend is dying my back
you can make these jump oh so she calls
me wolf interesting one pill one lousy
little pill who open the door she opened
it is it is she
[Music]
eg whether it's give it a give the
camera then don't see one
one word say the way through keep going
I got it guys have to go through the
barbershop everyone knows this you know
our dogs can play cards like that
you're the size of an eight-year-old Wow
body-shaming much Abby
unbelievable
looks like we're extending this gameplay
to five hours huh
wait how do I use
see if we can get to the top of this
building you've been to these sky
bridges before time hours let's go yeah
you think we're gonna see a lot of scars
sarah fights you gonna be okay if we do
you miss my face was yesterday you have
it
those guys were hunting you me too can't
see it enough
oh man here we are playing us our
favorite character playing our favorite
game this is playing it live this is so
cool they're tearing me apart Lisa watch
the glass like you did
room his better story the [ __ ] of God
taught me why he's all working on this
honestly not a bad idea all right we're
on the bridge damage let's be careful
watch out
okay
let's get off as quick as possible
getting closer to your tall building
dude you guys have nightmare from
yesterday
I could have opened the door
and that's how it's done yeah we style
oh my god two days someone said that
seemed that sexing was mocap just nice
can you imagine so you're gonna tell me
the real reason whether after you know I
did they want to kill a little boy
because he shaved his head I wasn't
alone so I broke it so why'd you do it
I don't know motion-tracking yeah
it means they wore the suits when they
did the sex scene I don't know if that's
true the thought of it makes me like hey
we got a safe and a sweet stereo I
should bring that back that's way better
than no ones do what a double screen
setup this is flip F save this everyone
on the planet have saves there's an 8k
in the save all right what's the code
LSS 30 2304 a lie you know what happens
if you're wrong right just so you know
are you ready to put your life on the
line
Ella you ready for beep be shipped
snip-snip Ella is safe
confirm trusted viewer appreciate it no
a key though sad
all right my phone is turning itself on
you make pipe bombs like I really missed
that last time I am a journey man on the
road again me and Maggie
[Music]
the limit minimum you're gonna come to
America mmmm
hey he's got such a good song great do
this some nice couches what they've done
with the place
some random bolts and [ __ ] I'll [ __ ]
take it
I'm Abby ain't nobody stop me silencer
or firepower we don't have a choice
we can no journeymen king Hofmeister are
they from Gothenburg I didn't know that
that was such a party song growing up in
Sweden
up
yeah now you get no my hand there my
precious hand oh god I just dodged it
too many times my bed group see I didn't
expect Tommy's in base [ __ ] set us up
come on they said of softer bomb
I got this
I got this watch this
watch this that's how it's done
they're gonna come out come on that's
good because I have a perfect a crazy
hundred percent a in breath oh god [ __ ]
is happening am i dying here is my
health low and I haven't checked it no
what is it
guess I'm just bad that's impossible
me bad at games
the best player in the world
all right I got it I got it what we do
is we throw bottle in like this and I'll
never expect it right that actually
works
yeah I should probably use the peepee
wrong
then for that I think I killed me
it's alright I think they're upset was
it something I said
well walking out
is that the clicker
what is happening [ __ ] I'm sorry all
right from now on Sarah des watch this
guy's
so no way in without making noise
there's an open window racing
now it isn't
oh there's an employee now okay let's do
this
[ __ ] I wasn't doing anything look away
for two seconds cuz nothing happened
okay
cool now we're back where we were yeah
dumb [ __ ] get ready it's fine this is
part of the plan this is part of the
plan to find this plan it's fine Martin
playing it's part of the plan this is an
elaborate plan but it's part of the plan
[Music]
the plan that's part of play so the
backside yeah click that that was
perfect so that's how it's done
how does it feel to watch the best
gameplay of last of us to out there
yes it's gotta feel pretty good knowing
you watch it's just like watching the
top shet make a frame heart heart I
don't know you know what I mean
am i winning son oh absolutely
you no doubt about it sir
pro-gamer moves right there like I was
cornered by a clip clicker click burn
that sushi and I just ran past it's
funny all right looks like we're gonna
have to loot a little bit I have no ammo
that's cool I don't really need ammo cuz
I'm Abbi
my muscles are my guns thank you very
much but you know it is what it is noise
alright we got some [ __ ] now can make
another pipe bomb explosive ammo I don't
mind if I do don't look speedrun
I'm not loading I'm just get out of my
way just clicking on buttons
because like the game wants me to eight
trophy probably for being so pro thanks
game for recognizing
that water's picked up a lot of speed
and needs to be really careful okay I've
done stuff like this
while aren't you cool oh god she did not
have a thing or he whatever hasn't been
specified so I don't know
watch this 360 yeah
and see on my phone is dead
I would give it a little bit more time
there's an otter pick in the set
settings
I should add to mine crime I'd be hella
dope can't afford [ __ ] maybe we should
have looked fried and some more there's
always like little trinkets close by yep
that's not enough
thanks for the one ammo guy you want to
see my face you miss it so much
Wow nice car
as more rooms in there I just can't be
fun
Oh
damn we're completely out on them
I think it's the drawers that are so
annoying it's like a lot of times
there's nothing in them even I say that
and then this
20:12 pewdiepie let's plays with no face
cam what is this damn I remember when it
was like frowned upon to have face cam
oh you just care about yourself
the gameplay should be more important
you're so eager centric that you have a
face cam Wow
it only face cam I only really started
because of horror stuff because people
wanted to see the reaction
it's kind of interesting how it changed
now it's like a standard for any game
but I do remember is generally frowned
upon for people to have face cam for a
long time and then it just sort of
slowly changed people's ideas around it
now no one cares good for your cousin
it's interesting things that upset
people in the fans
rumors stories shut the [ __ ] up back in
my day how are we going we're praying
Sunderman 2055 oh I think I'm gonna have
a stroke broke my would I break my head
show-off
a [ __ ] I walk around huh look at
Slenderman foundin look programming
jokes a programming nerds tell me the
joke explain the joke em Abby reads fast
impressive
Naughty Dog headquarters one day if to
make another last of us I'm joking it's
a great game I love it
finally this is a fastest selling
PlayStation 4 time no we're not fine
these it's [ __ ] crazy let's never
look up what does that mean it means no
matter how many people are gonna find a
way around you maybe you should stop
saying we
since they're trying to kill you they
call her the ax pasta or mean I'm not
really ready for a fight to be
completely honest how for [ __ ] sake
what did you not hear me saying I would
be right all right listen sensei
Oh [ __ ] on the fire you see that you
don't want to [ __ ] with me guys all
right let's use this Oh Mamma Mia
BPB at Jesus I wish to kill this guy
Mellie no I don't I don't have a rifle I
didn't have a rifle okay
it's one more talking to herself
no no yeah come in here come in here I
need to save ammo come in here
I'm speedrunning but need to yeah look
behind you
he's like where the [ __ ] did I go they
could be anywhere
behind me you fell for the old other but
then okay dumb [ __ ]
one more scissor and that'll do it wait
was that I can upgrade faster cracking
nothing let me help
I got it alright CIB just want to help
people that's our main character trained
even if they're the enemy I be just want
to help people
Jesus that's goodness in your heart skip
on it no okay
you're one more sister that'd be great
naughty dog dogs are listening thank you
bing-bong bing-bong my machete is strong
yeah twitch girl livestream chair tell
me I'm wrong tell me I'm wrong
item missing the sofa
Go Go I don't [ __ ] see you didn't
miss that though alright so we came from
there let's go through here it's our
whole way here yeah
the other sofa
she got some bread for us
no protein in bread only cars shoot it
killed the bread any more produce is
pretty cool
oh what's cool like impressive awesome I
wonder if your prophet had any idea what
she was starting
she saved dozens of people in waste no
one can explain she blew up trucks and
killed some soldiers not that hard to
explain
have you read her writings skimmed some
you'd benefit from it sure so why did
she get exiled from the group because
she's not wearing the haircut thank
everyone else
let me damage on the shelf and have it
being like a boss fight can't do it yeah
okay so it's a he my bad
some people are saying it's because he's
a trans
interesting I'll go first this time
it's interesting everyone thought Abby
was gonna be friends but he shaved his
head and only the girl the girls have to
have the haircut
okay that makes sense seriously he's not
Thanks
you should be proud
okay I see them Wow look at this wish I
could get a better view of that
hey Abby love us yes of course okay so
they split up
really tempting to shoot one guy in with
a crossbow but Allison need to save ammo
it so everybody to get across
oh there's crisis
making my way what the [ __ ] was that did
you guys see that it looked like a naked
guy why did it am ia crazy have I lost
the others a lot of them it looked like
one of those auric naked dudes like
super buff naked guy your mind is dirty
Felix okay [ __ ] my peripheral vision
sees what it wants to see I guess
alright so how does the inside of this
look
okay we'll get the damn how do they
breed these girls man [ __ ] they make a
bee look small
and you protein only oh it's an upgraded
machete bed now it exactly right
show your titty thank you so much for
saving Emma huh
[Music]
he jumped out all right you're gonna
have to do something
hello some more officers
one here
jump down
[ __ ] oh through the wall now what the
[ __ ]
love that sound so much yeah
sneak gang look at that sneak kill
[Music]
so how did how did you die from being
choked like that whoops I'm fine
the next snaps is that what happens
I cannot sneak as a be very really my
life depended on it just oh there there
hello damn the hitch up those side of
flying [ __ ] can't get their ammo no more
but where how we get your head let me go
there it is
nice shot reveal your sound thank you ah
what Beach
[ __ ] these scars Sara fights whatever
yeah never heard of Sara fight cuss
before I did nothing wrong
that was perfect just as I planned it as
always hard part coming oh no all right
I've pipe bombs it's all good
[ __ ] [ __ ] we have four pipe bombs
bruh I'm ready
Noel this is all going according to the
plan I've calculated this in my head
prior to this I knew all of that and I
knew I was gonna be down to one health
pack so this is honestly I feel good
about it where to now so the hammer has
one shot left but this is many isn't
this better than did you know the wrench
is a Swedish invention have I ever
mentioned me invention did I mention the
wrench is the Swedish invention craft
more durable Meli upgrades that would be
pretty sweet
okay like I need this can't [ __ ] see
them and it always [ __ ] me over [ __ ]
Yoink some bits and voids that right is
that an elevator yeah will they be able
to carry a B that's why she's scared all
right let's see on my camera soon give
it a little more time give it a little
bit more time
all right per stick you can press it
press the goddamn button hold on a sec
okay we should hurry though
yeah there's secret here maybe yeah I
found it guys oh okay I got to pull the
door closed of course it's a safety me
safety mechanism
I'm just not scared of danger that's why
I didn't think about it you ready
Savi's get it might give you some advice
think about the good first the good
parts
you run faster what a snow is you don't
feel penis I'll join the scars
the heart racing they're all signs are
artists
so when you feel free you should think
about how your body is getting ready for
only when they are very much history and
that what in speech inspired her to kill
Joel Wow she's scared how unique and
multi-layered Jesus Christ your anti
electricity and all that sinful world
stuff there are exceptions especially
for soldiers that's convenient
this is cool I like this area
Hey look at that Thole it was all part
of the plan you wouldn't listen I was
thinking how far you can hit a golf ball
from here
surely there's no zombies here are there
loot that's the real question
when do you hear
what the [ __ ] is that
that's the bridge love follow me
[ __ ] hey Abby doesn't like bridges I
guess we're not so different you and I
people cross this regularly
I like Abby yeah you're lying it's not
the most popular
what is she saying this is okay I
thought we had to Joe how how you
feeling I'm waiting on all that true
strength cool what paranoid what's going
on between you and your friend oh it oh
my god love now it seemed really awkward
just go
I did it yeah can we take a minute and
be impressed by me no yeah
I'm good why you'll see holy [ __ ] laughs
it's gonna be okay
eyes on me Oh
balance gang Khan I want to see the
animation of her falling gang but I want
to go through another deaf scene game
how are you not terrified of this don't
quote the Prophet to me Heights never
scared me lies the ocean
oh [ __ ]
damn how they do this
oh Jesus Hey look you can see the
hospital now let's keep a low center
over you - this love right I can't do
this yes you can damn cool
[Music]
I like this part Suffern Suffern yeah I
can't do it walk please oh oh oh
I was crawling I still have to balance
confuse noises the [ __ ] that I do how
whoever built this I can understand
being scared but just traversing it I
don't know was foreshadowing ready damn
it
please
okay he's yours out where you know I
don't know what do you mean this is the
right building but I've never been to
this part of it the bridge drops herself
at the back of the building this is new
to me okay well we can find our own way
down clean good thing there was a pool
underneath where the odds an indoor pool
it's chilling the hot nine Oh
had to check my fears arena that's the
worst of it we got off lucky maybe it
wasn't luck maybe it was some wolves
believe in God oh now the game makes
sense there's jinns well I don't if I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die for me then what
are you doing here
why didn't you come back for us
guilt what you don't owe us anything I
just wish I had this many dumbbells your
name fan man
there was a huge gym earlier that I
missed oh listen I respect muscle gains
on anyone but abacus doesn't it doesn't
look real that's the thing
there's a game about shooting zombies
and you care about religion yeah because
they're trying to make the game seem
realistic oh yes I care I'm not some
sort of like looking at enemy girls
going where are her organs ah it's more
like did this doesn't fit in my opinion
like they made some character in
uncharted 4 I don't remember her name
they made her really buff and it was
just kind of cool I got all my I don't
mind I think it's a cool thing I was
thinking it's the same thing with the
pregnant lady that's probably the
dumbest okay this is safe I'll look for
it the pregnant lady going out in calm
mind has probably one of the dumbest
thing in the game I feel like there's
few people that can refute that even in
a logical standpoint if you don't give a
[ __ ] about the baby for some whatever
reason you still have to carry that
[ __ ] thing around for nine months
just just from that perspective it's
like why would you risk all doing having
to do all that again unless you really
really really don't care and that's this
being generous with the argument but
then I was thinking like it could be
cool to have a really badass pregnant
lady it is a zombie apocalypse after all
like what if there was a lady that had
to pretend to be pregnant we met her in
the woods she was forced to defend
herself that could be like oh yeah okay
I'm praying the lady she's badass she's
going out because she had to you know
that's the difference here's this
someone that choose to do it and it's
just so cringy so I feel like a lot of
ideas in this game they're not bad
itself this is how they do them it just
makes me like that just seems too
obvious that the developer have some
intention in mind of what's
what's wrong and he just comes across
way to clearly and and that's the thing
like they're not even necessarily bad
ideas it's soaked Rangeley executed is
our way down there's the [ __ ] safe
did I oh god am I gonna miss the safe
now just a body god [ __ ] bears no
check out the clothes here rip effing
the cheap stock down there oh I see how
this works trying to fast today I'm not
working out
gotta get those a beer inspected in its
building we always take elevators down
to the bottom so I don't know I can't go
back in a [ __ ] out
I'm not complaining about the game it's
just like random ideas I'm still
enjoying it I don't want it to seem like
oh the game sucks like just a replay
spores masks on I don't have one do you
guys not believe in gas masks we were on
the run do you believe in masks gas
masks stay here
Beckett all the way if you die I'll be
stuck here mr. Brian I'm a kid
okay gas masks masks so a chance to get
the safe zone I really didn't see it
just stay up there okay
there's not anything that much spores I
guess a little bit is it now
pee break please I really don't have to
go you gotta go you gotta go
six hours left [ __ ] up No
why is this thing rolling around who do
you work for there's no one in here is
it
hey hey we got another gas mask finally
you're gonna kill yourself don't ask
nice one a B so much empathy on this
character dick you go your example you
should love Abby I love Abby my favorite
Carrie
dammit I hope for is anything we can
pull there
you can't go in there it look like we
could go up what about here maybe in the
shower look up seem to be the common
theme if you're stuck so I'll look up I
just see this that's clearly you can go
through there No
is there another room somewhere
holy [ __ ] this one working yes looks
good
all right back to Lev
why does it feel like every time you go
into an empty space and then you
complete the past tasks and you're
supposed to go back it just feels like
okay now something will go wrong [ __ ]
there's so much oh how about that the
cliches I don't see them
oh she's loose she lost her legs don't
touch me
stop stop it pity pie stop it
that actually worked out really well Oh
goddess no there were so many more oh I
thought I did it what the [ __ ] is this
glitch
my supposed to run just run I'm not sure
I remember like where I was riding
circle it's okay this is part of the
plan
they work that run game and then the
door is here okay sweet run gang are you
president don't need to wash the mask
look at Abby he'll be taking too long
can't move any faster I don't do your
sister any good ever book sense of
direction hundred thanks guys
we got this this is the Joel and Ellie
dynamic I wanted Ellie being Joel and
this one being Ellie what did I just say
daddy being Josie you're way down
this is actually better le being Joel
yeah that's what I've been oh okay sorry
this is where we came from I remember
that I was just checking to see maybe
like new loot spawn or something like
that yeah I know I was going the wrong
way come on fringe I opened the door
just just to check check it I guess you
can find with us now right
the zombies are gone now it's all good
should we warn her about that me what
about that it's part of the plan yeah he
my bang hey shoddy in a firehouse no I
mention she is a become get this moon
coming yeah yeah can you help me
the [ __ ] are you doing Tommy that Oh
well where will is the safe on this
floor everyone keeps saying saved I
can't trust you guys anymore that's a
thick rope dude take that rope it's damn
I respect the thick rope
I really do it's a fire hose I knew that
[ __ ] sake
what are you taking me for this feels
like some Zerg [ __ ] star crack [ __ ]
shake shake shake
I've dish enough violence out all right
what do we got
whoa that come from the wall gang wall
bad [ __ ] this yeah shoot that [ __ ] Hey
look titty did he survive
impressive Hey
[ __ ] wall game [ __ ] knew it
gotta watch out for walls now
demonetized gang no no no dude
yesterday's video didn't get to monetize
I'm like bro so we can't go this way
let's check in spores it's a big
building we saw it before
[Applause]
stop moving your hands I think I learned
at a couple of them let me save that
ammo thank you
tape click ya can make a silencer but
feels I've ever done let's make this
[ __ ] going we're gonna save that ammo
yeah whoa we're supposed to go here
suddenly a be not scared of heights
whoa that what Oh flamethrower is real I
saw it in the comments I couldn't be
[ __ ] to even comment about it hey gang
it goes through her burn gang that's
what [ __ ] happens sealing gang Nick's
bra you coming for you oh oh great we
gotta help pack phenomenal wool game -
oh whoops snack game
my supposed to jump there oh this feels
like a trap
shiver required anything else hey might
if I missed night
and the apples now we can make ships
I don't give a [ __ ] about faster
crafting 105 mill a cura see that's why
y'all subscribe to watch this pro level
oh no it's the Fett peacemaker I always
think I would go this way anyway let's
pipe on this [ __ ]
I missed a Gundam suit [ __ ] a fatty
one chump how are you not dead he dead
cheeks though someone made those think
about that okay
sorry speedrun I'm bad we're going yeah
I'll get a pipe
we're not even supposed to be here
said ah we could have just snuck past
them I know that because I did it
where the [ __ ] installed the toilet
there what is it a toilet thing who are
you working for I get it's not okay jump
gang alright this is this is a wall this
is a wall [ __ ] step aside actually you
refer to me by go-go it's not a trap
it's definitely not a trap over there
come on leave I go you [ __ ] daddy's
still scared me [ __ ] balls I ain't
[ __ ] walls oh I hate walls
[ __ ] you Levi you knew so can we jump
across here
turn another wall here [ __ ] wall gang
okay so we don't have any more explosive
who can actually make some yeah all
right we're good on ammo now I say that
just wait
and this place is fun
I missed something where don't go the
proko a lot of times things glister and
it's not oh I have three but I craft two
at a time understand it's probably gonna
be a fight down here don't you think oh
god no it's not Oh a mattress that's
what you get Abby
now I understand why she feels Joel it
all makes sense
all right surely now I should have the
knife brain hold Brett studying my aim
mmm
I really want me to do faster crafting
I'll say for that I'll say for crafting
hunting more because we tend to play
more aggressively we I say we as in I
can't sell a my man give me day hey 8
buck God [ __ ] god damn it
is that a wall that's a wall that's some
wall right there you see that wall Levi
you go Levi
no no no no no no yeah [ __ ] you all suck
it how do you become a wall explain that
explain that to me makes no [ __ ]
sense
fringe yeah I don't think I can make
that jump I'm being honest not my best
day doesn't look like this anything
there anyway
this is what happens when you join the
wall gang let that be a warning for you
kids out there you easily influence
children never go full wall gang oh can
i grab something [ __ ] I can't I die
gotta let it go
god damn let's jump off the window
can't side
[ __ ] cringe wall gang yes sir
spit don't work alright where do we got
walls [ __ ] off the walls Levi please
is he wearing Levi's jeans that'd be so
epic that's what I would do my name is
Levi
I actually don't want to press this
might not say that where do you know
what
all right we got two three four five
let's get this guy first I think I have
ships hey girl
what you got there it's a boy it's a
wall
kill the wall oh this is bad it's a wall
tore up a piece of his body part of I'm
part of the plan
part of the plan by the time
[ __ ] throwing [ __ ] damn I need some you
bar the pine it's all part of the plan
it's all part of playing brother all
right leave I should do something every
right all far the plan all pipeline open
a plant or put a plant the pine is
falling apart the plan is falling apart
I'm not gonna lie god damn it let me
thank you hey how you doing
you want to let me heal
[Applause]
surely thank you all right that went
pretty well
we did it they killed that big demon
yeah we did yeah this is a zombie I
would be if I if I have died and zombies
just imagine is tearing up your [ __ ]
throw it at people I'd be [ __ ] funny
I know I wouldn't be a wall in these
cringe
alright let's save our flamethrower a
little bit let it rest let it cool down
part of the plan
upgrade this yeah sure
wait it's not a wall up in walls they'd
really knew you were gonna go in here
first they set that [ __ ] wall [ __ ] up
I can't craft anything right alright
remind me there's a bottle there in case
we find something else I saw this
earlier
beep you break plates disco it just go I
really don't have to pee I'll be here
there's no words my bladder huge out you
know what they say huge bladder big how
many people are watching doesn't have
jars brings
let's go [ __ ] this building
reload gang no weapon gang jump down
game and get it waited for leave that to
move we're full of snack right our
health is fault yeah no more bottles
please I don't want that sheet alright
more enemies coming
probably through that door let's check
around first nailed it nailed it nailed
it
top-tier gameplay 100% accurate zero
that's so far if you're watching you
take your mask off thank you you're
welcome
sliding game looking for a little while
sliding game nice expensive outdoor area
it's right there I see it remember we
have to go back all the way as well
please don't let me play that can I ask
you a question okay
do you regret shaving your head we're
not supposed to have regrets laughs I
wish I just ran away she'd be back home
taking care of her mom
does your mom need taking care of Oh
it was a safe where shut up show about
the safe there's no save Levi is sang in
Airbender no way got the same hairstyle
yeah the gym was like an hour ago
we're in the last hour of Abby this is
as far as you go
wait why because they want to kill you
with me they're just worried about a
backgammon rematch what's back in I'm
gonna go in the front door Oh grab the
stuff come right back
you're staying here yeah yeah
why am i tempted to go here okay let's
go okay so they got the light pointing
there where do I go then
I'm just a frog being by about oh the
snare Sarah and
they're my allies be serious all right
we made it to camp okay that makes sense
that's why you're gonna stay I was
paying attention to the story too much
that I missed it I'm a wolf don't shoot
it's me it's a B a B it's a B [ __ ] open
the gate so they just know the names of
everyone or how did they must have some
password or system Jesus you swim here
Bo got [ __ ] I need to grab some
medical supplies I'm doing a thing for
Isaac we're moving all these assets to
Isaac what does he need and I can't talk
about it it's something away from the
FOB well everything's getting moved out
and packed up take a look see if
anyone's got what you need
hey is Nora around yesterday she said
she was shipping out here just left the
last transport but she'll be back okay
thanks everyone doesn't know Abby
how you doing boy oh [ __ ] this is why we
broke in with Ellie before remember I
remember
oh how lovely nice a little fire going
thanks guys appreciate it
Joel bus fight
Abbi you get to swing the club later
yeah I need some medical supplies can
you put me over heavy she's checked in
with Isaac he wants you back at the farm
let me talk to Isaac talk to him in
person
going back to the next shipment sorry
what are you doing she's been a while
since yesterday were there dogs on that
pile you alright
[Music]
you're gonna just okay your shoulder
well I never thought I see you and I six
bad side you find one at the aquarium
I talked to Manny I need some medical
supplies why what happened to him
compartment syndrome bastard forum
you're not treating him are you no have
a lot of time Jesus most of these
supplies have been packed and shipped
already what we haven't cleared out the
lower floors yet would they have what I
need
yeah probably but it's rough down there
she seems like a genuinely good person
feel better
Ellie kill her so horrific elite you get
caught I had nothing to do with this of
course come on compartments Angela
[ __ ] yeah always lucky he's a doctor
I'll do it okay fine she was so [ __ ]
up after I said talk to her
I really just smack it since Mac
bing-bong back Isaak interrogated all of
us he was rough on her did anyone talk
oh I like this part where the game you
just walk really so it's my favorite
bits
Nora where are you two going to grab a
bee boats ready to head out well I still
got boxes on the third floor can you to
bring them first boats pretty full come
on I don't want to be here all day fine
thanks I guess what they were going for
is that and you're okay they knew where
you would hate Abby but then you they
wanted to change your mind
step by step so you would realize
yourself hey there's different
perspectives and then different
parallels of one person's enemy is
another person bing-bong you know he's
been I just feel like I've done the
trick for me I feel so bad for Mel yeah
for anything a lot of the details that
you have found out about Abby was just
like the trauma center and a few
surgical suites it sounds perfect
there's a reason we haven't touch this
area yet it was ground zero for the
whole city
they brought the first infected before
anyone knew better it's gonna be
overgrown - [ __ ]
awesome to be fair like it would have
been better to start off with Abby but
at the same time if they did that you
would have just been like why the [ __ ]
am i playing is Abby no matter what it's
like one hooker my bling is happy why am
i looting worst case look for ambulances
they're contained and I've gotten lucky
before yeah we played a baby for like
ten minutes
the point was they could have changed
the order of things and he might have
been more impactful
Thank You game hey or survival belong
may my death be Swift
see you back a base soon I hope yeah
Abbey is based on Colleen fudge damn
that's a strong woman
god damn it's that true they base it on
her or is that just some people say but
it's like that's someone that dedicated
their life to their body
it's impressive at how I looked away now
I don't know where I am
okay surgery trauma ICU let's do this
they still don't look similar I would
just CrossFit can we jump over here no
it's a nice place you fought the good
fight
things might you telling me they never
cleared out their own offices hello
still at 47 huh I missed an item where a
lot of supplies here you guys set a
difficult part is coming up but it never
happened
I hate our you can't like if you reload
you shouldn't be able to pick up more
ammo right
I missed one but it should and what do
we one cut more yes yes speedrun coming
right up so much you're looking here I
love it can't open it don't like it er
trauma centers gonna be in there
did I walk in circles
nice place all right they'll definitely
be zombie Singh this looks so cool
Oh God not the wall game are you doing
that Mike
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] I see you [ __ ]
ain't afraid of a [ __ ] wall
shake shake shake the kid we didn't
shake shake shake
clickety clickety this cop part is
getting boring I did a bit boring
okay I want to play as Ali
I'm doing I looked so fast
come on give me something yeah found it
to be something around here that's some
wall thank you for staying a wall Oh
[ __ ] Ewing's it's not going there yet
what's happening in here guys
they put the sick people in here that
doctor puts some ointment on my bite
mark and then vanished that'll do there
you go is a point man for you sir and
that'll do just fine
the hospital will send a bill in the
mail
how we're doing in here boys anymore
wall gangs nice else
we need blood men so there's this door
and then there's this door
I assume this is lock then oh no no no
this door gonna be busted open excuse me
yeah power ok follow the cables sorry
mm-hmm it's all wrong how it helped me
live blah blah blah
we came from here right or did we
yes we did cooling right okay
so power maybe from the main center dam
a little peace fella snack for later
protein okay then the power must be over
here surgery Adam oh [ __ ]
that's a lot of them
[Applause]
spooky [ __ ] the balls man goddamn
another one please don't [ __ ] me
I can break that window but then I'll
alert everyone so I can actually just go
around
there's a hard part coming up that's
fine I seem to struggle at the easy
parts that's my little thing all right
it's definitely not sure where to go in
there seems like a bad idea let's go
yeah it's the only door here somewhere
okay so Abby says there's a generator
why don't we follow the cables cables
going here and then they go in there
okay
hey Frank didn't think we could walk
everybody we can
he's 11 here Manny yeah or Ellie any
nanny would have agreed yeah let me suck
bing-bong going
when you get stuck look that that's
right that's like old it's so true it
seems to be the case so many times full
I'm [ __ ] Pole you guys told me not to
waste that I will come back for more
Emma when I use it then let's upgrade we
can't upgrade the fire launcher ok first
fire no curbs and damage yeah hell yeah
that'll do like brand new do you need to
do damage on this one
the door needs power but the lamp is on
like usual
hey don't question the game how dare you
alright that's good for now wish you
could do like camos on the guns like
maybe like a CD pie skin or this is
definitely gonna alert some people
they could have just made us have to do
that before we upgrade
alright let's use the plane it doesn't
matter if I reload I still can't get
more ammo it's kind of annoying
yes
Oh Bama well yeah that's the style
[Applause]
[Music]
whole new part of the planet so I go up
to the walls and I hit them nothing
happens but when it's convenient judges
run passes that should make things
easier and where the [ __ ] are these
medical supplies supplies [ __ ]
damn that's a lot of pills
yeah I could go back to the room
I'm alright [ __ ] sake please don't be
an ambulance in the garage can't really
be fun yeah I was just about to thanks
guys
Oh
[ __ ] it let's get it it wasn't that far
nice so now we can take it so if
anything I can just shoot one shot and
then it picks up all the ammo right no I
just picked up how much I could okay it
was 25 I only picked up ten things that
don't matter
that's me yeah I did it guys
punched him did that that was [ __ ]
sweet damn it I need a scissor
this room was just a distraction
all right let's watch out for the
[ __ ] Wallace we need to cancel them
nice place
okay now we can go in here sweet so
there's a big scary boss in here isn't
it
wipe the mouth like if she says don't
panic but I can't see anyone
and crawl under you
nope Abby to stick
I don't like this
it's too quiet
I think the game wants me to go here
don't spam me last chance I'm about to
meet Coco melon
[Music]
I'll go outside the animal
god damn
whoopee
run gang up it's fine daddy
you're scared of heights remember not
zombies
okay I go like
[Music]
cool
I just hope I don't make it wrong I feel
like oh
[Applause]
that's compete I thought it was like oh
you took a long time you died
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] that could be like bruh
flamethrower okay I'll use that it's
thin
they're not [ __ ] ready
doors are killing me
keep wine
what there's two of them
no [ __ ] Jesus Christ I should have
saved my
Oh
I wasn't sure if that happened yet
like dying here
chunder fleas
John the John Doe demo jungle jungle
jungle
junga junga yeah
first try good oh yeah definitely worth
upgrading back goddamn say oh that's
[ __ ] yeah that's what I'm talking about
pro gamer right here you're watching one
of the finest collects player glass is
that find the only one the old
commitment
I was a big Chinese moment
[ __ ] you're supposed to be dead that's
not very big Chandi
I'm into
I got bad feeling about this sappy song
I got real bad feeling about it I only
have five ammo left on the flamethrower
[Music]
we can make a pipe bomb or we can make
plain memo zombie running away do they
have consciousness well well well I
guess we were the bigot all along just
because they have lack of brain function
doesn't mean they stole my ammo
[ __ ]
I just sound like a horse man
that was a [ __ ] headshot
[Music]
how does not being life be like yeah
first try so that I like this place to
be spooky spooky scary skeleton can
never Daniel spine lip lip lip lip
fitted
[Music]
I cracked this boobies
quick supply check then and we'll be on
our merry little way damn Abby must be
such a compassionate person to go
through all of this to save someone's
life they should never met before even
though he was her enemy both be scary
Gator dude dude dude dude I really
admire Abby's compassion for other
people and not seeking blind revenge
such a cool character development that
happens backwards
no more zombies come on I'm done
I thought the entrance is here
oh cool this is los all right cuz
they're at hospital but I'm next
what's the [ __ ] door here a
safe going through here don't have a
video game [ __ ] no wait no wait
there's a safe
don't go safe looking for you what did
you do nothing I told you to stay put I
couldn't your friends are all over the
place did you get the stuff yeah I just
need to put the hell out of here
how much more Oh me
you
[Music]
beyond my life
I think that moment legit more impactful
than anything I was getting such a look
as a dog we killed remember thanks game
[Music]
what's the point the dog dies
shift your weight huh well done you can
go see her now if you want she's gonna
be okay yeah actually that's cool they
did us spooky area I like that they're
just kids I know
what happened us
maybe we stopped looking for the light
but my audioletter can't do that can do
that
go check on the girl okay you're all
just jab Joey
yeah sorry about your arm bro
[Music]
all right cool this might be interesting
are we gonna see Joel that's me when I
see Joel
yeah flashback flashback in guys
[Music]
nope gutsy your dad before he win
Batman flashback are we done are we done
ah it's cool to see I be maintaining
those gains she's working out all the
time
which flashback at this
two billion hours ago Bowen [ __ ]
longer they're gonna I was changing her
his bandages can't believe she's on her
feet already no scars were tough what
are they fighting about love doesn't
want to leave see how it is a nice way
this time to come to Santa Barbara but
it's his very own I figured you'd have
talked him out of going by now actually
I'm going with them but not if you come
he may fall free little act with these
kids but I don't there's nothing to fall
for her where's the team scar killer
suddenly had a change of heart nothing
to do with Owen right I haven't always
done the right you're a piece of [ __ ]
Abby wait till she find as I double tap
team you always have whatever it's
called to to time I'm done with you you
want to do right by these kids get out
of their lives before you screw them
over sorry but you don't you don't get
to tell me how to do right by kids
uh-uh
Abby not chair again okay
nice shirt are you are you okay
how's your arm every night oh god it's
actually I'm thinner than it was this
morning I can feel my leg I've coming
around he will would you mind helping me
look for him he's pretty worked up
right off this way
I leave now I go I don't go
so someone said that this is a pretty
true recreation of their aquarium in
Seattle which is kind of cool y'all need
to stop why doesn't want to go to Santa
Barbara she's worried about her mom
about what'll happen to her because of
us
shitty was a lifetime he needs to focus
on his own safety right now what could
happen to her sometimes parents are held
responsible for their children's sins
but I'm home is so devout not come
she'll probably be fine
are there still permission for helping
her he can't convince her to leave
no one could I'm more worried of what
she did to him love I'm sorry love
you know I wonder if he saw this he
loves sharks love sharks but hates the
ocean though he really opened up to you
we've bonded over her shared for me
dying you hear that love
whoa that's cool
hey it's okay it's okay she just wants
to play hey girl
what you got there she won't hurt you
okay watch go get it [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] pricks hey here's that dog
you killed now you're gonna play with it
would you feel bad for killing his dog
good job
typically you kill the dog bro you wanna
try that doesn't seem like a good idea
she's not going to bite right nope I
promise
that's the worst I guess I can't judge
what can I do it again no no I think she
would love that
keep the hog tuned
my turn
and secret get out doesn't let me we
should keep looking for him
let it go let it go don't hold day-dawn
any mo game makes you feel something
it's done and strong I guess so
I mean that's why I was thinking like
I'd rather slightest games than a really
mediocre sequel hey do you think maybe I
could convince your mom she saw him like
this she'd strangle him with her bare
hands I'm actually curious how they get
those scars did he tell you I never
honestly not much I heard some of your
people calling him Lily
for a long time I didn't understand why
he was questioning the laws traditions
when he explained to me how he felt
inside I told him he had to keep it to
himself
I was hoping it'd snap out of it he
seemed to fine
for a while then he shaved his head okay
so he wasn't that guy was suicide is
that when you ran first I screamed at
him I hit him
stupid
yeah I have an idea when we find
somebody chairman
why do you think he did it now shaved
his head I mean last week he got
assigned his role in the community he
wanted to be a soldier like sir cool but
they decided he was to be a wife to one
of the elders hmm where is Santa Barbara
yes Seattle's in the north of California
what the [ __ ] that's what I was saying
California
okay so look this is Seattle and this is
Santa Barbara oh my god Island it's too
small to see but it would be up here I
knew it wasn't California I said Noir
I didn't know what state it was good god
Dan don't make fun of me so much huh
there's gotta be something laughs around
here yeah I remember now Washington I've
been there it's a really cool place
we can do better than these shirts the
shirt I have sleeves on them I just got
to show off those guns not that I
managed that there's a zombie apocalypse
and you probably want to protect your
arms about whatever okay cool I think
nothing
this plate this sucks I'm sorry Jesus
Christ oh my god what am I going what am
i doing
it's the point I'm picking up a shark
baby shark today today baby sure did -
you did it - the baby sure - dude you
today baby shirt you dirty this it's
perfect
oh we were actually smells wrong No
you don't know me I know enough
Abby will you stop stealing my stuff
please I'm sorry I didn't realize you
owned everything in the aquarium
yeah well my aquarium my stuff I was
kidding
take for everyone you can't have you
seen love uh yeah he's down that hallway
okay can't talk to you oh good job
she couldn't tell us joking I suck with
kids yeah they really like you though
so um come to Santa Barbara right she's
got a Cal goal you know why
we can figure this out
it's too late no no it isn't I know
I know it's [ __ ] this I know this is
a perfect example of just moving on but
we can choose to be happy
right
we're allowed to be happy
this makes me dislike every more like
everything what's he doing he's going
after her after who his mom she's gonna
kill him Abby
a few hours
well head him off well grab the boat
from the marine informational body get
there how else am I gonna find like how
did it happen go Owen oh you know
they're having the [ __ ] island not
gonna let her go by herself
actually you are
I can help ya by staying here in fixing
the [ __ ] sailboat your priorities
straight
er let's go
again like I don't think mine I think it
could have been really cool I just it's
just so over the top my god can I get a
break because I want to pee oh my god I
be done just know I thought it was
[ __ ] ally for a second Jesus Christ
are you doing
all right break time dude wolves use
this place go pee
we got some bro strange okay
all right sorry I'm a little cranky
I haven't even anything not a fast
blood sugar levels be like brah right
now I apologize for all the common it's
all good now
it's all good I'm sorry for what I said
when I was on good
okay
well not making that
here I've got you I can do it let's go
careful
so how do we get to your village in
peace in her blind spots along the coast
we've been boating - from there we'll
follow backwards their safest option you
have any chance love is gonna change of
mind
no she's stubborn does he get what he's
walking into not he did it's got a soft
spot it's his mom Angie's here it's not
bad game
trance anything with dynamite in it nope
about the camera froze trolled you aha
don't need that
where's my craft man
I should go for
okay so nothing two and three we maxed
out for five gets more durable [ __ ]
how do we get to the marina from here
looks like a lot to go around
down this way I really miss plaintiff
everything
before it was okay there was some really
cool parts actually a lot of scenes with
Abby we're actually the best ones
imagine it with alien dude like the
forests been in the dark so dope Wow
and hospital single-vehicle too
war
over here that's our language the pain
of being hungry it's like entering it
feels good
it's like going against common sense hey
go go yes I guess cell phone
the trick is to go through it without
getting angry I can do it this is the
ultimate test of stoicism for feelings
thing is Abbey
while being hungry there's a way through
here I can do come on
boats are across the water over there
he's got to go up to the road and go
around hey sounds good closing this
forest
yeah
it says so [ __ ] snow goddamn it
I love was that ten seconds here you go
you're welcome
speed-read day in those fast
I got the pills bro
just 10 more hours guys we can do this
oh yeah for that matter
stand the duck I'll go get a bowl to
pick you up here no I can't help how
many hours honestly
well it sounds like there's some
shooting I look forward
I like the head shots in this game
yeah
snipers [ __ ] frog what are you doing
out here
votes we're supposed to get the islands
Runa I just hop for dinner
I sent the guy to call my before backup
should be on the way
no I can get them any one of those boats
now why that's me later then I guess
you're gonna help me take this guy let's
do it
seems dangerous and irresponsible let's
just lay low so are they on the left or
right don't worry we'll get it kill my
home team don't worry we got [ __ ] these
trespassers are you
what trespassers that look like you came
from that Tower is our nice cute sucker
are they on the bridge
this way
surely they should anticipate our
movement a down the bridge this is a
Volvo guess we could go over those in
the woods all around should we do it to
that front he's got in the open you
don't say
some water deep enough
Schaech go in the water
can I go under the truck all right you
can go in the trucks right oh cool
whoa that [ __ ] wasn't expecting this
I'm buying
I'm literally buying whoa big reveal
forgot I couldn't swim
Jago in the amber lens
well
I'm crashed and he holds breath it was
actually useful should I get it yeah
anything else in here baby shark duty
duty baby Shakti duties I'm saved you
wanna do let's get inside of that garage
users know this is cover it's fine it's
got a leash that jump I did oh [ __ ] bro
game remove should be going after death
Sara that still on unique never done
before man here lives
shouting like a melody in my head no no
no
and stop singing I'm gonna write it I
didn't sing it was my own song original
song I wrote myself called
more the Bing bong Bing Gumby yeah those
are the lyrics don't call I'll call
right you poke the melon didn't come up
with baby shards you'll read them to us
oh that was cool
about the No
it's a pretty cool action gameplay
happening live you're watching live the
toughest thing I'll ask my own song I
wrote it
thank you come on that was pretty good
game plan you can't lie don't lie to me
we shout and look for that I should cry
somewhere hemorrhoids I upgraded to the
max to the maximum we jump in the
elevator it's a zit not sports yeah
what did you go can the gun far can he
just assume the gender of the sniper hey
me fake it is am I supposed to shoot him
or should I that's being shared
[Music]
just shoot him I can't really
oh yes I feel like this is a chase scene
I can't tell it
it's Joel he's cornered come on let's
flush him out
nothing yell at he's cornered you could
have taken him by surprise
No
it
it's got to be a certain character
I'm not looking at chat this way okay
I glanced at checked out of reflex but I
saw don't release [ __ ] like to Isaac
it's a dog
yeah that's it Manny three two one it's
Allie
three two one stressed about
never can be
[Music]
okay okay so we were definitely not
supposed to shoot
isn't it am I wasting Ellie's bullet
mmmm
Jessi it's Tommy
yeah it's gonna be Tommy that's right
that makes the most sense
- Isaac Riley of course of course
it's right here
it's like a waste but I don't have this
oh my god do they not use blankets
[ __ ] sake waste blame them
guys stomach 100%
they're safe
where are you that means we're not
No
you all right I still watches what's up
it doesn't matter let's get home it's
fine come on take that vote
everything
we're a hundred k people watching this
[ __ ] what's up [ __ ]
god damn thanks to all the members shout
out big PP all across the board
you're watching what I'm in the finest
Let's Plays of Lazarus hundred percent
head shows the sale representatives
subscribe I'm kind of a pro gamer in
case you haven't heard of misspoke don't
Google my name do you know where he's
going
most people would crouch in there but I
went brown how far is it across the
island you dip yourself with any water
and they'd give you more armless most
people wouldn't Crouch here as well oh
look this is squirrels you secret
achievement if you cross me are you sure
the wolves are attacking tonight yeah
that's what my friend told me they'll
use this story doesn't cover the attack
unless Isaac changes its mind your
leader Isaac what does he want an end to
the fighting no what cost at this point
any cost
Abby's friend died she doesn't hear how
you could climb in there it's the
fastest way dude Abby's ponytail is
freaking out
Abby control your ponytail no it's
coming alive it's like one of those Zerg
creatures at the back of her head
nuts argh alien control your pony
it's a French braid oh I'm so sorry
I sure feel stupid now oh you're right
safe here a lot of people miss applies
just in case bra no legs are with our
legs sorry and soon how's it hanging
Jesus I'm sorry about your friends is
what it is it is what it is
Abby compassion ed everybody needs
I do want to look at that because I hear
village no that's Haven
ours is further inland don't linger
damnit remind me to crap the exam oh
let's stop crushing there what is that
it's our warning signal where people are
tear
the whole island is on alert now we need
to hurry
how do I do that you don't mind this
character how many soldiers
what are the other half gonna do when my
people get you some will hide most will
fight
all right let's stop this [ __ ] watch me
do perfect stuff gambling it they got
[ __ ] cow I mean lambs bro I got a
check them out how are we doing here
boys that's my girl
how we doing what's going on oh that's
mine oh you best believe it's shopping
time
why would you set up new buildings and
stuff like that we're gonna be safer you
know what all right
full time I had to play for maximum ten
more minutes and then I gotta go because
I haven't even an asterick
speed-read where is everyone fighting
no one's watching the camp
may her light guide us through the
strong they really like her huh when
you're lost in the darkness
look for the light what's that something
my dad used to say
yeah I guess you didn't think that's a
heart did you happy
and he looks cool
you need a climate there
hope
somewhere I heard that get the moves
right
there's a bazooka in the house okay call
I'll look for it thanks guys
it seems like the kind of people that
would have bazookas around
this is bad I'm gonna get through this
the gate will be locked the lumber mill
the big building on the right with the
torches that gets us out of here
yeah we can got through it sending the
kids to the ranch
no supplies
okay they build walls and [ __ ] that's
kinda cool that makes sense then oh god
they're [ __ ] everywhere
[Music]
and I wish you could move body
kind of wanted to shoot her
[ __ ] it what I said no find who did this
bing bada boom bada boom
Abby is the extremely something or did
date or George or did think it's all
good
justise plan this is part of the plan by
the way
I call this the stealth strategy not a
lot of people can pull it off on you say
how you stopped here
see the game wants you to think that
you're supposed to stealth this area but
in reality life doesn't always work out
like that so it's really a lesson in the
game about animal head all right
I'll hit this one the first one is
always a
[Music]
growing they weren't [ __ ] on and you
know it
we can't go through there
there's only two guys left right
but they have better weapons do I have
ammo oh nice okay that states theta
surprise okay we just randomly ducks oh
there
reveal yourself
whoa Daiwa's Hakeem sweet dude
there you are
don't shoot don't shoot don't shoot
don't shoot
I think he knows where I am
what are you guys reckon all right what
about this he didn't fall all right all
right what about my account oh wait oh
wait I can't get it with a shotgun
I can't with a bomb bro man's got
wallhack this ain't fair
oh my god a b-movie your [ __ ] head oh
she sucks
meg you'd be like birth what in the
world is wrong with you Abby
that was an innocent all right watch
this headshot boom all right here he
comes
are you ready for 100% accuracy yep yeah
nice shot daughter oh dude I like you
she's a keeper I think I can salvage the
legs you'll never find me I'm invisible
someone guess what you get for skipping
like that
[Music]
see now is really the part that you want
itself in the game a lot of people would
probably have stuff the whole entire
thing that's not you played the game
dude they're society's awesome why are
you destroying I'm sorry I want to see
if I can take her out without wasting
where'd she go
they have barrels good Society pick one
pick one
should go though for real
just keep moving
down here okay just beside me it was
crazy
no I can't go back up now speedrun
that's what we're doing anyway alright I
gotta wrap this up Isaac what are you
doing thanks for joining the string guys
she had to pursuit gap [ __ ] alright
we'll get it next time do that actually
say there we go
ish thanks for joining us thanks all the
new members appreciate yet
good times we're had we'll see you next
time
in the next part at bay
not much trolling today I appreciate
that they do appreciate that Ellie will
probably be in next stream so that's
something yeah join the disk or join the
members join the fun bro please there's
a new video if you guys want to check
that out that's it it'll